by this time we know how to construct
confidence intervals when we try to
estimate an unknown mean of a certain
distribution using the sample mean as
our estimator or actually these are
approximate confidence intervals because
we are using the approximation suggested
by the central limit theorem but what if
we do not know the value of Sigma the
standard deviation of the axes then we
have a few options one option is to use
an upper bound on Sigma so we will be
using a value that's larger than or
equal to Sigma and this is going to make
our interval somewhat larger so this is
a conservative choice but it is
definitely an option for example if
we're dealing with Bernoulli random
variables we know that the standard
deviation is less than or equal to 1/2
so we can just plug in the value of 1/2
at this point another option is to try
to estimate Sigma how do we estimate it
we can perhaps use an ad-hoc estimate of
Sigma that fits to the particular
situation at hand so for example in the
Bernoulli case we know that Sigma is
given by this formula where theta is the
mean of the Bernoulli and using this and
since we do have an estimate of theta
this is just the sample mean we can plug
in that particular estimate and that
gives us an estimate of the standard
deviation when n is large this estimate
is going to be very close to the true
value and so this estimate of the
standard deviation will also be very
close to the true value both of these
options were discussed for special cases
where we have special structure and we
can derive an upper bound or there is a
natural estimate that suggest itself
more generally what can we do one
general option is to use a generic way
of estimating the variance and here's
how it goes the variance is by
definition
expected value of something of this
expression and we can estimate expected
values by taking several samples of this
quantity and taking the average of them
so if we have n pieces of data for each
piece of data we calculate this quantity
divided by N and by the weak law of
large numbers the this is the sample
mean of this particular random variable
and it converges to the expected value
of this random variable so that's how we
could estimate the variance but there is
a catch
this expression here involves the mean
of the random variable and this is
something that we do not know so what
can we do well we have an estimate for
the mean so we could just plug in that
estimate instead of the true value and
this gives us this alternative
expression now when n is very large as n
increases this sample mean converges to
the true mean so this expression here
will become closer and closer to this
expression now this expression converges
to Sigma squared and we conclude from
this that this expression will also
converge to Sigma squared and so here we
have a way of estimating Sigma squared
from the data and by taking the square
root we obtain an estimate of Sigma as
well that we can plug in in this
expression and this gives us a complete
way of coming up with confidence
intervals when we only have data
available in our hands but do not know
ahead of time what Sigma is some remarks
this procedure of constructing
confidence intervals involves two
separate approximations one
approximation has to do with the fact
that the sample mean is approximately
normal according to the central limit
theorem and then there is a second
approximation that comes in in use
an estimate of Sigma instead of the true
value of Sigma now when we estimate
Sigma instead of using the true value
we're introducing some additional
randomness in this procedure and because
of this randomness the confidence
intervals actually should be a little
larger there is a systematic way of
doing that and it involves using the so
called T distribution tables and those
tables are going to give us certain
numbers that are a little different from
what we have here so instead of 1.96 we
might have a somewhat larger number this
correction is relevant when n is a small
number let's say n smaller than 30 but
for larger values of n this correction
where we use T tables instead of normal
tables is rather insignificant and one
doesn't bother with it in any case we
will not discuss any further this
additional correction but it is useful
to know that it is something that
statisticians will often do finally one
last remark one will often see an
alternative way of estimating the
variance who are instead of this factor
of 1 over n the one uses a factor of 1
over n minus 1 with this alternative
form it turns out that this is an
unbiased estimator of the variance and
that could be a reason for preferring to
use this alternative form on the other
hand when n is large whether we use n or
n minus 1 makes very little difference
and this concludes our discussion of
confidence intervals